what do you think starts the problem
though so it's like if they went to
these forums or to these YouTube
channels or whatever like something had
to start it where it's different today
than it was 50 years ago what do you
think that is I think you know just with
with the Advent of of social media and
stuff like that and there's there's just
so much like like this Tinder statistics
right it's like if guys aren't using
professional pictures the first thing we
do when a guy signs up for my my eight
week programs we get in professional
pictures and then Liz and some other
girls on the team pick the top five and
then we apply face app so they're going
from like average photos to Pro photos
to the best five Pro photos to the face
app versions and now they're getting
like a night and day difference in the
quantity and quality of matches whereas
you know before they might have just put
up whatever pictures didn't get the
result and then they see their friend
maybe like one of their cool guy friends
he's getting a lot of girls but they
don't know how to navigate that properly
but then when they look on social media
they see you know all these perfect
looking people and they say well I'm not
perfect looking right and I have these
flaws and